[Music]
you're used to being in front of like
far bigger audiences or as big audience
but I mean this is a little bit out of
the comfort zone it's gotta be oh my god
100% you know rustling I've been doing
it for 10 years I know it it's a part of
me I've just started learning this for
two weeks and sort of come out here and
be fearless Nikki but show I have dance
moves it's so scary you look scary is it
just me it was crazy but then all of a
sudden chin up for my my quiz and then
I'm like out of my comfort zone now I'm
freaking out
[Music]
and sir are you alright how'd it go like
did you get hurt how many times you
practice how did you learn I mean what
the heck look you know the baby's got
body sweat holy is the body's time
actually didn't I mean it hurt but it
didn't hurt like this and then of the
routine that hurt because this floor is
wooden if isn't bounced and lifted him
even higher than usual and then your
pendulum
I know you know it just moment how do I
slam someone who looks like they just
died and not like give him a one-two
exactly their guts low circle I like
every WWE fans guys after Nikki Bella's
debut performance her husband John Cena
shared a sweet message in his absence
tweeting stepping out of your comfort
zone isn't easy and I'm so proud of her
what are we gonna see the big man here
in the ballroom in a few weeks in a few
weeks he's probably a little busy yes he
has no mercy this Sunday so he's been
prepping for that he just flew him from
China
so once he kicks Roman reigns buzz and
he will make his way over here
[Music]